una idea recurrente cuando estudiamos
economía son los cuatro factores de
producción que usualmente se enlistan
como tierra trabajo capital y
habilidades empresariales y la idea que
está detrás es que si tú quieres
producir lo que sea digamos que ese es
el círculo de los procesos de producción
y está flecha es la producción entonces
necesitamos insumos ahora puede que
tengas muchos muchos muchos muchos
insumos tal vez necesites suministros
tal vez necesites una fábrica tal vez
necesites trabajadores
necesitarás todas estas cosas distintas
pero la idea de los cuatro factores de
producción es que todas esas cosas que
vas a necesitar se pueden clasificar en
alguno de estos cuatro grupos ya sea
tierra trabajo capital o habilidades
empresariales ahora bien estas palabras
tienen un significado en nuestra habla
diaria y bueno tal vez algunos de
ustedes les llame la atención
que si necesitan construir una fábrica o
necesitan cosechar entonces necesitan
tierra para ello de hecho lo podemos ver
en este ejemplo aquí podemos ver una
granja y claramente necesitan mucha
tierra para ella e incluso en una
fábrica de ropa como esta otra
fotografía una fábrica de hace muchos
años cientos tal vez no sé incluso allí
se necesita tierra para construir la
fábrica este suelo es tierra y la
palabra tierra en un contexto económico
no solamente tiene el significado de
tierra de manera estricta también puede
significar cualquier recurso natural en
general puede simplificar el agua o el
aire o la energía es por ello que en
algunos contextos en lugar de tierra
algunas personas dicen que este primer
factor son los recursos naturales
ahora bien otro factor de producción
importante bueno puede decirse que todos
son importantes es la idea de trabajo
para producir más y mejores productos
alguien tiene que trabajar en eso
alguien tiene que plantar las semillas
hay quien tiene que recolectar la
cosecha el trabajo se ve claramente a la
derecha estas personas están trabajando
para producir algo ahora
capital es muy interesante significa una
cosa nuestro lenguaje común y algo mucho
más específico en un contexto económico
en un contexto económico el capital es
algo producido para producir más cosas
ejemplos de capitales serían las
herramientas que usas para producir
otras cosas podría ser una construcción
que necesitarás para producir otras
cosas o podría ser la maquinaria para tu
fábrica así que en estas dos imágenes
hay varios ejemplos de capital por
ejemplo puedes ver las mesas y las
herramientas que estos trabajadores
están usando eso es parte del capital
puedes ver todo el edificio adecuado
para producir y las lámparas así que
todas estas cosas son el capital
otro ejemplo las perchas donde cuelgan
los abrigos después de producirlos eso
es capital y en el ejemplo de la granja
el capital serían estos edificios que se
construyeron especialmente para producir
comida de la granja
parece que tenemos un tipo de maquinaria
este es el capital de la granja ya que
sirve para que salga la producción de la
granja ahora capital tiene un
significado económico que es diferente
al del uso cotidiano porque en el día a
día cuando alguien habla de capital a
menudo incluye el capital financiero los
activos financieros podrían ser
utilizados para obtener ganancias en el
futuro por ejemplo el dinero pero en un
contexto económico no estamos
considerando los activos financieros
sólo pensamos en las cosas producidas
para producir otras cosas
el cuarto factor son las habilidades
empresariales habilidades empresariales
en nuestro lenguaje diario significa
poner las cosas juntas así que si estás
tratando de crear un producto imagina
alguien que está intentando empezar un
negocio es decir que es un empresario en
un contexto económico habilidades
empresariales tienen una idea similar a
eso habilidades empresariales significa
poner en conjunto todos los otros
factores para poder producir es decir no
puedes construir fábricas o sembrar
semillas de manera aleatoria alguien
tiene que pensar en cómo poner estas
cosas juntas para obtener productos de
una forma razonable yo obviamente
querrás producir lo más que se pueda
dado los otros factores que tengas para
producir otra idea que a veces se usa de
una manera intercambiable con
habilidades empresariales en un contexto
económico es la idea de tecnología así
que algunas veces puedes ver los cuatro
factores de producción como
tierra trabajo capital y habilidades
empresariales y otras veces puedes ver
enlistados los cuatro factores de
producción como tierra trabajo capital y
tecnología pero cuando ves a la
tecnología como factor de producción no
pensamos en la palabra tecnología de uso
cotidiano como cuando piensas en
circuitos integrados de computadora o
software o algo así cuando alguien habla
de tecnología como factor de producción
está pensando en habilidades
empresariales está hablando del
conocimiento de poner juntos todos estos
factores para tener una producción
finalmente quiero dejarte con una idea
la idea de que hay dos clases de cosas
que se pueden producir con todos estos
factores de producción
hablando de manera general nosotros
podemos producir algo que se pueda usar
para producir más cosas ya hemos hablado
texto puedes estar en la situación donde
produce es algún bien de capital por
ejemplo podemos construir una fábrica
que tal vez produzca herramientas para
que otras personas las usen en otros
procesos de producción la otra opción
que tenemos es producir lo que se conoce
como bien de consumo los bienes de
consumo son bienes que sólo se usan es
decir podrían ser bienes que hagan
felices a las personas o podrían ser
bienes enfocados en el placer pero no
son bienes que se usen para producir
otras cosas y dado que los recursos de
producción son escasos hay un
intercambio en la decisión de una
sociedad de cuántos bienes de capital
producir contra cuántos bienes de
consumo todos necesitamos bienes de
consumo sino francamente
siquiera vestidos o lo disfrutaríamos
una rica comida o no seríamos capaces de
disfrutar nuestras vidas pero
simultáneamente necesitas bienes de
capital si solo hiciéramos bienes de
consumo en un punto no seríamos capaces
de tener todas las herramientas para
producir bienes de consumo así que
sucede un intercambio muy interesante
que exploraremos más en vídeos futuros